I love that we have a cutout
right behind you, Andy,
of a woman who just doesn't seem
to be enjoying the show that much,
to be honest with you.
She's holding a pop doll and has like,
a caricature shirt of us.
[Conan] Yeah.
I don't know.
So she's clearly a big fan,
she just doesn't love
this episode of the show.
Right, or she just needs
a medication change.
That's always a possibility.
[Conan] Yeah okay, and
the guy next to you.
Oh, this guy?
[Conan] Well no, well
first of all him, yeah.
Talk about him needing
a medication change.
Yeah.
Even this kinda, I mean, it stinks.
(laughing)
It smells sweaty.
Even the cardboard thing stinks.
[Conan] Even the cardboard
smells like sweat.
Yeah.
Once again, I just have to say,
I am thrilled that so many
of our fans sent in photos
allowing us to make cardboard cutouts
and fill our audience.
They really all seem like lovely people,
except for one.
Caleb.
(ominous music)
I just despise Caleb.
I'm up here working hard,
trying to entertain
America during a pandemic,
and everyone's happy except Caleb.
Thinks he's so much better than me.
Looking down his nose at the
performing chimp up on stage.
Oh Caleb.
I think I hate you more
than anyone in this crowd,
with the possible exception
of that guy.
Jordan.
Why, why did we put a cutout
of Jordan in the crowd
pretending to be an illusionist?
What?
Andy, what would possibly be the point?
The only upside to this quarantine
is that I don't see Jordan regularly.
We went to the trouble, somebody,
to have a cardboard cutout of Jordan
put in the crowd to glower at me.
Yes.
Well actually, it's funny
because the cardboard cutout
is far more productive
than the actual Jordan.
[Conan] Yeah, the actually Jordan.
Look at him!
The actual Jordan does so little.
Yet the cardboard cutout is just
kicking ass and taking names.